hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a little clip from
my conversation with brandon sanderson
the absolutely incredible best-selling
fantasy author who is my favorite author
of all time and in this clip we're going
to hear brandon's thoughts on creativity
versus originality and how we as
individuals can be more original and
cultivate more creativity in whatever
our pursuits might be so i hope you
enjoy this clip so one book i have on my
desk at all times is austin cleon's
still like an artist i don't know if you
come across it how do you think about
like other fantasy writers and like
getting inspiration from them and and
also vice versa like
you're such a huge name in fantasy that
lots of people are probably now
massively inspired by you so how do you
think about that in terms of
like ideas and collaboration and
plagiarism and all that kind of stuff
yeah so i think in general authors worry
a little too much
about coming off as derivative and
things like this
now your early books are gonna feel
really derivative that does happen like
my first unpublished book feels very
derivative this is why we don't publish
our first books and it's really okay i
am never going to
fear like
i'm not one that's afraid of being
plagiarized right like
you authors develop their own voices and
their own ways of doing thing and if you
give two authors the same concept they
will come up with wildly different books
and i think that
really the way that human creativity
works is recombination what we remix
that's what we're really good at we
don't we don't come up with a new
wholesale creature we put a horn on a
horse and look at that that's cool
that's like how we create just on a
fundamental letter level we don't
imagine a color that we've never seen
our brains aren't equipped for that what
we can do is we can imagine something
that is usually one color with a
different color and kind of play with
that and theme and things like that i do
think that you do have to be worried
about um
a little bit about being derivative but
not terribly much in my class with my
students i talk about the difference
between what i call a chef and a cook i
am a cook when it comes to actual food
this means you give me a recipe and i
can follow it and generally get the
thing that i'm supposed to be making
but if i do something wrong or if i
haven't accounted for something i have
no idea how to fix it if the recipe just
doesn't turn out i'll have just no clue
a chef would be able to say oh you're at
a different elevation that causes this
effect that's why this bake turned out
differently you need to do this thing
and this and tweak this or your butter
was melted and it was too melty and so
you got this result as a writer i
encourage
my students to try to think of
themselves like chefs rather than cooks
which is
train yourself to look at something you
love and break it down to why you love
it on a fundamental level and then
rebuild it into something that is your
own and i think that's just a very
useful skill for creators to have and
this is where you start to make these
connections where you're like wow a
buddy cop movie in a co and a
romantic comedy often have the same plot
structure why is that why what are we
loving about these things how can i use
an element from that what is a heist i
love heist movies can i create and you
end up with something really cool like
inception which is a heist but unlike
any you've ever seen it follows the
heist beats really well but it still
feels wholly original because
christopher nolan and his brother have
broken this thing down and looked at
what they really love about what makes a
heist work and then they have created
their own version of it that does
something new and original and
if you can learn to do that if you can
learn to to boil it down to what you
love and take that core element and
build something new around it you will
be a successful storyteller i am
convinced yeah it's exactly the same
with for example youtube as well like i
teach a lot of people how to how to do
well on youtube and it really is this
case of look at other people that you
like the videos of figure it out figure
out what it is about those things that
you like and then think about
incorporating those into your thing into
your own videos
and not worrying too much about like
originality at the start because
in your quest to be like someone else
that you like you'll end up finding your
own voice and kind of doing it your own
way
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye